وبشاني اتفاقه وقت القتال في السودان الذي
تم توقيعه في جده قال بيان سعودي امريكي
ان الاتفاق يدخل حيز التنفيذ في التاسعه
وخمس واربعين دقيقه من مساء اليوم الاثنين
بتوقيت الخرطوم ان الاتفاق ستدعمه اليه
مراقبه مدعومه دوليا من قبل السعوديه
والولايات المتحده وذلك لاول مره منذ بدء
هذه المواجهه وتضمن الاتفاق انها طرفي
النزاع في السودان التزم بايصال وتوزيع
المساعدات الانسانيه واستعاده الخدمات
الاساسيه كما التزم بسحب القوات من
المستشفيات والمرافق العامه الاساسيه
قال الجيش السوداني ان القوات المسلحه
السودانيه ملتزمه بنفس اتفاق جده على وقف
اطلاق النار الذي سيدخل حيز التنفيذ اليوم
واشار في بيان الى ان الاتفاق سيقتصر على
الجوانب العسكريه والفنيه الخاصه بترتيبات
وقف اطلاق النار المؤقت
اضافه الى الترتيبات الخاصه لحمايه
المدنيين والمستشفيات ولا يتطرقوا للقضايا
السياسيه
في المقابل وصف المستشار السياسي لقائد
قوات الدعم السريع في السودان يوسف عزت
اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار في جده بانه خطوه
جيده وايجابيه وقال عزت ان قوات الدعم
السريع ملتزمه بالهدنه ووقف اطلاق النار
وذكر ان جديد هذه المفاوضات يتلخص في
ضروره تشكيل لجنه لمراقبه وقف اطلاق النار
وقد تم اقراره في الاتفاق الاخير في جده